si de buenas noches raúl luego realizó
una rueda de prensa el día de hoy para
animar a sus seguidores a que acudan de
manera presencial mañana a esta consulta
simbólica también esta consulta comenzó
de manera online el 7 de diciembre y
según guaidó ha sido un éxito y ha dicho
que es un instrumento de lucha para
llegar hasta la comunidad internacional
y mañana se votará en 78 países los
venezolanos pueden votar en 78 países en
335 municipios del país están
habilitados tres mil puntos y siete mil
mesas para ellos también se espera que
la mayoría de personas que acudan a esta
votación sea las personas mayores que no
han podido hacerlo con las distintas
plataformas online que fueron
habilitadas para hacer esta consulta
popular
así es termine entonces gracias por la
información por supuesto muy pendiente
de lo que ocurra en caracas venezuela-
buena noche